hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to hey
everybody it's January you know what
that means
probably my keys are just made it up
it's Nickelodeon Mod Nickelodeon the
first television network made for kids
by kids well okay not by kids though
it's stupid but certainly the first
television network for kids this was a
groundbreaking channel with a
groundbreaking notion and what did this
groundbreaking creation give us mostly
British and Canadian shows but we didn't
care it was on all the time that is
until evening when it was switchover to
older adult shows uh Nick at Nite but
even those were so unwise Alandra dick
Ulis that we enjoyed them too but let's
be honest after a while there's only so
many weed runs and syndicate shows that
they could run so Nickelodeon finally
made the logical choice to produce their
own material and what was the result
Nick to a series of cartoons made
specifically for the Nickelodeon champ
there were many of these cartoons that
they even continued the trademark name
of Nick tunes
even to this day but we were there when
they first popped up and don't you
forget so let's take a look at one of
their finest and certainly strangest of
shows Ren and Stimpy a lot of people
have mixed feelings towards this cartoon
then there's a good reason it's friggin
insane little made sense and half the
time the humor came from just how
totally out of control and psychotic it
was and it kick-ass sure it was gross
and vulgar but on the other hand it was
gross and vulgar kids love that kind of
stuff and this was one of the first
cartoon shows to totally engrosses in it
I mean no other cartoon looked or acted
like this it was something completely
different
so how do I really describe what this
show is like what stars a big dumb cat
Nate's kid being an angry Mexican
Chihuahua named Brett yo sick little
monkey and the rest in all honesty is
pretty much like talking to a kid on the
ultimate of sugar hot hey kid what do
you want to see MTV I don't know have
some cash
I want a gentle push together cuz buns
are funny
I'll teach your grandmother to suck eggs
one of the biggest controversies about
the show is whether or not red and
skimpy are gay to which the creator of
the show John Kay answered I don't know
that's none of my business could be
honest I read about this show before and
one of my countdown so I'm not going to
go into too much detail but let's just
say the show definitely knew how to
capture the craziest side of our
silliness so let's move on to
Nickelodeon's other biggest hit Rugrats
this was made in a more innocent time
we're crawling babies were funny men
with purple hair was acceptable and
keyboards synthesizers seem to rule the
earth the show was pretty much about
babies and that's it it was pretty much
just about babies so they dealt with
tough nail-biting dilemmas like can't
the dog come with us or do we need to
take in them or if you want me to do
what Arthur they call it gettin
potty-trained actually this episode is
probably one of the most fans as it
talks about what all of the kids love to
talk about shitting they're trying to
make me who's fat instead of my diaper
that can't happen oh this is just too
precious maybe you could just stop
pooping all together and that's just
gross maybe you could put amount of
napkins in your parents and you don't
like a diaper that's even grosser maybe
you could poop in your room and not in
your toy box okay stop stop look we'll
be caught poo pee or poop or whatever
it's still shit you're talking about
shit knock it off you're grossing me out
oh that's charming they can't make me
I'm gonna lair by divers forever and
nobody just gonna stop me
don't worry a kid when he gets be 80 I
have to wear him again anyway thinking
of growing up I always imagine what
these kids would look like when they
eventually got older I think everybody
imagine that like Chucky would grow up
to be Darth Tommy will grow up to be
Paul Giamatti twins will grow up to be
John - Joan coos egg because they
already look alike and the always
power-hungry Angelica well for some
reason I always saw her as Hillary
Clinton I can't help but it's just the
first thing that popped in my head
actually something I always noticed
about these cartoons is that they always
open in a strange way that is they
usually do an extreme closeup of
something and then eventually back off
to show us what it is that sounds fine
and good but what happens when the image
almost looks pervert in like this one
it's to pay chomping is it the inside of
a woman's what that oh it's the inside
of a dog's mouth panting ah though the
other kids are cute I guess the one kid
that everyone seems to remember is
Angelica for being such a brat little
bitch
yeah little babies really make me laugh
she's dummies know anything yeah
everyone remembers how harsh she was but
here's the thing she's so mean that
she's actually kind of creepy don't
believe me look what happens when I put
her face over these disasters
but not even Angela and all the
negativity can prepare you for the
scariest
most horrifying creation that
Nickelodeon studios has ever produced
dog not perhaps some of you are
wondering why I think so harshly of what
appears to be a relatively harmless
cartoon well let's just say you knew
someone with a very similar name someone
who grew up with that name all its life
it happened to be raised at the exact
same time this show came out do you
think any jokes are funny remarks in
connection with this show could possibly
affect his life in any negative way do
you
like
whoa excuse me hi
just having another one of my random
psychotic episodes brought on by this
very show luckily I did take a one's
life this time but with that said but
with that said this was a pretty lame
show I mean the show was pretty much
just about a kid who went to high school
and that's it it was pretty much just
about a kid who went to high school Doug
or Doug funnie if you want to know his
full name has some very odd friends like
mosquito Valentine bud dink his dog
porkchop and Patti mayonnaise what is up
with these names what you did have room
for Johnny picture frame Larry toilet
paper or Suzy contraceptive huh he
spends most of his time going after
patty mayonnaise because well she looks
pretty and apparently that's all he
needs she's just as bland as I am also
what is up with everybody's skin colour
in the show did the Tom get infected by
radioactive poisoning y'all bad let me
take care of this they never liked the
new people on top of that the music
always sounds like it's literally
farting out its soundtrack just listen
we're gonna need a faster tempo Howard
more pork and beans there's also this
bully named Roger who constantly tries
to make Doug's life a living hell
why because all kids with leather
jackets are just bullies now did you
know that it's like an official law he
also travels around with his pet cat
named stinky he probably lives up to his
namesake this show is so unrealistic I
mean what kind of boy would travel
around with a cat where leather covered
his hair and gel obsess over his looks
and constantly co-actor a submissive boy
roughly his age old I think the best way
to describe this show is that it's kind
of like the early episode of The
Simpsons they're not funny not well
animated and surround you in a world of
awkward uncomfortableness but whereas
The Simpsons got funny duck just
psychologically tortured me for a wife I
mean psychologically tortured a
they've done for life - OH ah
Rocko's Modern Life this show is kind of
like Ren & Stimpy except maybe a little
bit more reserved and not quite as
controversial but I did capture a lot in
Jose Diaz as the show's main character
was a tiny kangaroo with an Australian
accent who for some reason has a
gigantic holiness this must have been
the Battle of the boomerangs koala bears
and Wallabies you know the Great War of
the Australian stereotypes whether
dingoes go high into the night attacking
the armies of shrimp on the barbie
but the ancient League of fosters bombed
all the alligator hunters leaving
nothing but the Kangaroos and eucalyptus
leaves to bathe the darkness or so ever
Rocko also has a cast of interesting
characters most notably a cow named ever
was kind of like an inbred version of
the starfish from Sponge Bob
Phil returned --all who looks like Woody
Allen is just as slimy and of course the
big head who I swear are just the
Grinch's testicles that they sprouted
legs to start complaining about
everything oh it's not in cabin sounds
so fancy you know I used to be a man but
I thought my voice was too feminine so I
changed Rocko himself is a pretty normal
and innocent character but the
adventures he embarks on certainly are
not
for example there's one episode where
Phil bird is looking to practice
dentistry on his friend so he takes him
to the Academy of dentists where he
performs in front of a stadium of people
but that's not the weird part he is then
taught by a teacher who is a cat with a
hook for a hand but that's not the
strange part one of Morocco's teeth
breaks loose grows seven stories high
and starts attacking the city by
destroying all the buildings while
Dilbert tries to dress up like the Tooth
Fairy to stop him but that's not the
strange part no
the strange part is this hey kids my
name is Gooden
let's talk about welcome
and now his truth condition you get
there so far as fucking weird as many of
these jokes get sometimes they hit a
little too close in familiarity like
tell me this bitch sounds familiar at
all I never really wanted to be a
dentist anyway I always wanted to be a
chimney sweep I didn't want to be a
barber anyway I wanted to be a
lumberjack leaping from roof to Oldtown
high rises leaping from tree to tree as
they float down the mighty rivers of
British Columbia and I'd sing sing sing
sing I mean there's paint omage and
others just plain ripping off and I
needed these were balls of great
comedians have to stop all right enough
is enough this is the final this is a
very very last draw well at least we get
some originality from the next show that
popped up ah real monsters now I have to
admit I was just starting to get out of
the nickelodeon phase when the show came
out so I didn't watch much of it but
what I did was a pretty cool show all
the monsters look creative than him
really funny enjoyable personalities the
story was about an academy of monsters
whose job was to go out into the world
scare the daylights out of people return
back with a report of their partners gee
would it be horrible as some other
successful studio pawn that office their
idea how much it so the lineup you have
take is who kind of looked like the
noise from the Domino's commercials
crowd who looks like how most people
look after laser eye surgery just
keeping it real people and don't bleed
huh kind of looks like Beetlejuice is
dildo
if he had one I guess she's supposed to
have some sort of accent but god help me
if I can tell you which one they've got
to do something if humans are not afraid
of him thank you
fear of all monsters it's like somebody
said this character has an accent okay
what kind just an accent they all have
to work for their intimidating boss
known as the ground who ice where's the
cartoon version of Tim Curry from Rocky
Horror Picture Show sweet transvestite
on this show was good but I always had
the feeling that some of these jokes had
a double meaning like listen to some of
these lines and tell me if they sound
decent have you fucked good boy oh yeah
oh our mothers and fathers loves each
other very much
yeah hey what hey what if you see a
monster just saying
coochie-coochie all right Noah's going
to what you go around my monster I just
supposed to use two fingers next
character all right this is the last
show I'm gonna talk about because this
is when I officially stop watching
Nickelodeon I actually never saw a
single episode of this show but I know a
lot of people did so I decided to take a
look at it from what I can gather it's a
show pretty much just about a kid in the
Bronx and that's it it pretty much is
about a kid in the Bronx
it's a tough time where kids walk like
they're a production of West Side Story
girls repeatedly shout the word Arnold
for some strange reason
and an army of boys against an army of
girls ultimately results in the boys
very politely stepping out of their way
I'm high there's a boy named Arnold who
was blessed without the pressures of
having a personality his best friend
Gerald the one black person that every
white person claims to know and then
there's hell who's so tough that she
actually names her fists they're gonna
have to answer to Old Betsy that's not
so tough I named my fists - this is
Glenda and pancake I know it doesn't
seem very threatening but when you look
at the job if they had to deal with
tough nail biting City drama then
everybody in the Bronx has to deal with
like again even though Helga constantly
makes fun of Arnold she secretly has a
crush on him that quite literally drives
her to madness
oh go in love you
and yet I hate you and I love you hate
you you Arnold we love him so much sir
which leads either the heads of summer
also maybe it's because I don't watch
the show but why does Arnold wear a
plaid skirt I mean is it a kilt is it a
jacket is he just an open transvestite I
mean Brooklyn that wouldn't surprise me
but come on how about a little
clarification yeah well from whatever
reason I guess the show didn't seem that
bad from what I saw but sadly I've
reached my peak by this point I had run
older and Nickelodeon cartoons no longer
seemed entertaining it strange to think
that for all the loud of bizarre shows I
remember Nickelodeon AG had a lot of
quiet and subtle shows as well
it was like the mood swings of
children's programming we loved it every
last bit Nicktoons were different
surreal and one-of-a-kind making it a
very memorable part of our childhoods
and trust me when I say I'm not really
as bitter about the whole Doug show as
eyelid on I mean it didn't leave nearly
as bad a mark as you amazing singing
it's going back going back I like to do
this I'm the nostalgic